[Music]
let's just get to the point good your
body is second that's Fallon right I
always say that this is the best shape
you have ever been in your life it's the
best exterior shape I've ever been in in
my life I've never fought it's true I've
never focused on like it's not some
weird saying it but sculpting right the
body right it's more interior and Warren
only the brave and all that kind of
stuff but it was good because the every
time I'd kind of referred back to a
picture of Ryan or something it made me
angry and then it made me work even
harder because this guy's like looks
like since shave 24/7 I on the other
hand am not in shape 24/7 sugar yeah
it's bad for you how are you how's your
interior shape no seriously like you
know interior shape is like doing stuff
like running and then this and sprinting
and I think you saw Lee where you know I
didn't mean like emotionally or
spiritually or anything like that but oh
that seems pretty good too okay right
now it's good yeah feel good in my life
right now it's good but the exterior
shape like you know I work out at Gold's
the mecca where Schwarzenegger works out
and all that kind of stuff so you start
getting tips from everybody and all that
it's fun it's fun it made it fun she
loved it Boeing it she loved it but I
don't know everybody goes god she must
have loved when you were in shape and
you know you're married the right person
when you're not in shape and she loves
it even more yeah not that she wants you
to be like horribly out of obese we like
our doughnuts and we like to have fun
together so when you're in shape all the
time and you're in that kind of mode
you're not as happy
that's very true no that's not I don't
want to put that out there it's not that
you're not as happy you're just focused
okay and it's kind of nice to like me
now you can only cut a great dessert
thank you it's not even lunchtime what
has been the best fan me
chin you've had since the Avengers
infinity war came out alright I mean I'm
sure you might without spoiling anything
you might have upset one or two you know
what I I upset that I think the best
reaction is the fact that I haven't only
upset people right like people actually
feel for this guy will actually
understand what his intention is people
actually have made you meet some people
are empathize or you know I mean some
people are actually on his side's wild
to see all the different reactions to
this guy people invest in the character
and that's cool the fish photo yeah
what's going on there
wider to where are you truly in the buff
with that fish really completely and
fast not even like a you know it's song
no why would I wear the ball I don't
know don't wear thongs easy to god
that's fish love what is it fish love
dot coat UK which is my buddies attempt
at getting people to stop overfishing in
European waters okay so it wasn't like a
reach out to know I just I'll taro about
like no no like I want to do a romantic
comedy with me so I'm gonna take a
picture naked with a fish with a
mackerel
hoping that you'll be attracted enough
to me to want to do a romance we trust a
little bit last night about Ryan
Reynolds is singing and there's a lot of
singing references in the film there's
also frozen we've got you know basically
right I need tomorrow I want to know why
we didn't get to your you saying because
from your Instagram with Katherine you
know you belt it out morning I heard it
I saw it you heard my voice you saw it
and now you want
Stan but you know what I heard Ryan sang
in Korea I don't know if you've seen
yeah we talked about last night well
that's what we talked about last night
he's good
no it wasn't it was great it was no like
we did it at this a o-l build thing and
I listen to it and they put it for they
like play the whole thing and I got on
the floor
I was crying laughing it's great man he
was so uncomfortable
brilliant who do you think would win in
a fight Thanos or cable and let's just
make it an arm wrestle
you've got the Infinity Gauntlet you've
got your cyborg arm who's gonna take it
but you can't have the Infinity Gauntlet
in an arm wrestle because he yeah by the
way that's okay Infinity Gauntlet with
no stones in it versus oh that's good
good I would still have to say fans okay
then I just have a thing about banners
Hugh Jackman and Ryan Reynolds have a
famous bromance if you come to visit the
set at all what do you make of that bro
he didn't come to visit the set but I
know you and Hugh comes across as nice
as he does I think he I think he's a
really like him and there's an evil kind
of twin brother thing going on there and
I want to stay as far away from that as
possible
Hugh is too nice he comes across as too
nice a dark feeling isn't it oh my god
who's your Hollywood bromance do you
have one yeah unfortunately it's Ryan
Reynolds Ryan is Ryan I have you know
what I got to know him on this tour
better than I knew him on the film did
you and I really started to like him on
the tour on the tour yeah the most
surprising thing something we might not
expect to think I was surprised that
once I finally I accidentally walked
into a bath
that he hadn't locked and I saw his
little Mimi and I thought just given
that he's Ryan Reynolds he's tall he's a
big guy's a movie star
that I didn't expect that and it's
really really really small thanks for
that that's arable I'm reassured that
it's ETS
[Music]
[Applause]